let's talk a little bit more about the
beliefs of Javier Malay because he does
have very strong beliefs you know you
mentioned him in the context of trump
bolsonaro Orban uh there's a tendency to
kind of like lump all these people
together which I think is a mistake and
part of what we're going to disentangle
a little bit here
um I watched a 2019 tedx talk that
melaye gave which was really an Ode to
capitalism uh we're gonna play a bit of
that and then discuss melee's
intellectual framework a bit more it'll
be subtitled in Spanish and for the
audio only podcast I will overdub this
in English but here's Javier Malay at
tedx in 2019.
amor
ous
foreign
[Music]
he sounds very much like a Libertarian
Economist there we'll get some of the
spicier stuff soon but Eduardo is a
fellow Argentine libertarian Economist
what can you tell us about relay's
economic ideas well at the beginning he
was an economy econometry economic
econometrist so he believed in planned
models and just studying statistics you
can foresee what the future would be so
he was working for corporations trying
to give them some kind of sense of where
the markets were going but without a
solid base of understanding I don't know
Israel
kirsner or some Krishna or the good
Economist of explaining uh Hayek that
what is the dispersed knowledge in the
economy so he just he didn't have too
much knowledge related to it but once he
started to study Mrs Hayek roadward in
Argentina Venegas Lynch that he was a
promoter of Austrian economics so he is
little by little he started to believe
in the Market processes and it started
to buy them so
it's true what he's saying in his Ted
Talk what he's saying that he really
learned how the markets operate and also
he started to realize how capitalism
transformed the world in the last two or
three centuries so when he saw that what
he saw the effects of the Industrial
Revolution and he started to realize
that the type of life we live today a
consequence of changing ideas and a
little bit of John Locke a little bit of
Jefferson a little bit of Benjamin
Franklin a little bit of John Adams and
Alexis the talk wheel I don't think he
really read them in in deep but he got
that feeling in and after that Argentina
has been a fascist on socialite social
socialist country for several decades
suddenly he discovered over that the
idea that necessity creates rights the
idea of social justice the idea that uh
that the wealth is fixed and when you
make money is at the expense of somebody
else a kids start to discover that all
those ideas are wrong I don't know how
deep his knowledge is related to this
justice issues but I really think that
he has the proper sense of life he
become little by little a kind of
individualist
he is probably his still a little bit
altruistic a little bit Mystic in uh
just in in some approaches but
the sense of life is individualistic
he's in favor of
he if he if you ask him how to interpret
and defend property rights or he can do
it if he if you ask him about
um the your right to look for your own
happiness he knows how how it Justified
that so I think that compared with some
other politician he's a strong leader
understanding some issues his character
is too strong for my
my
pleasure the way he speaks he looks like
Benito Mussolini but still the the way
he approaches subjects is pretty good
the way that he's been portrayed here in
by the U.S media is I just pulled her
together a little Montage of headlines
Argentinian far right Outsider Javier
Malay posts shock win in primary
election in Argentina a new Trump Rises
far-right populist Javier Malay is the
biggest vote getter in Argentina's
presidential primary New York Times far
right libertarian so uh they did
describe as a Libertarian but a
far-right Libertarian wins Argentina's
presidential primary and then I just
want to dig into the New York Times
description of his policy positions here
for a second he says that they say that
besides his ideas about the currency and
the central bank which is something
we're going to get to later because
that's that's Central to the Malay
candidacy I think uh but they say he has
proposed drastically lowering taxes and
cutting public spending including
charging people to use the Public Health
Care System closing or privatizing all
state-owned Enterprises and eliminating
health education and environmental
Ministries
um you know uh I that that all sounds to
me like fairly straightforward
libertarian policy
um and uh the Spanish newspaper El Pais
had a rundown of uh some of his
positions on social issues uh
but uh marriage between people of the
same sex for me marriage was a contract
between private individuals says Millay
homosexuality sexuality is lived as
lived is a personal choice drug
legalization they say that melee is in
favor of drug legalization because his
consumption is an individual action
uh they say the same thing here about
gender identity uh malays kind of spicy
statement here is do you want to
perceive yourself as a cougar do it
doesn't matter to me as long as you
don't make me pay the bill don't impose
it on me from the states right
um he wants to deregulate the legal arms
markets which means allowing legal uh
Firearms ownership
um he says he's not an advocate of the
military Argentine military dictatorship
although he
is taking a look at what buchelli is
doing in El Salvador that may or may not
be of interest to him
um I should also mention here that he uh
supports a referendum to undo
Argentina's recent abortion rights law
so he's anti-abortion he's also trying
to wage uh some of the same gender
studies schools fights that are raging
here in the U.S
and last thing here is he's expressed a
uh
a natural alliance with figures like
Trump and Brazil's bolsonaro because he
says there he's on the side of anyone
against communism and socialism
um but I was saying earlier to Eduardo
that I I don't think it's particularly
Illuminating to say that Trump equals
bolsonaro equals Orban equals Malay
especially because Malay
well we may have some criticisms of him
does look different from the rest but
Gloria what is your overall reaction to
the kind of far-right characterization
of Javier Malay well I think and and I I
agree with a lot of that is important to
understand Argentinian history in order
to understand the massive ignorance that
there is especially in Latin America of
what the libertarian movement portrays
for example myself I was graduated from
universia Francisco Moroccan UFM I did
an internship at the Cato Institute I've
dedicated my life for the libertarian
principles and to diffuse them not only
in Latin America but elsewhere in the
world and now I have people saying that
I am not a Libertarian because I don't
want the state getting involved in
issues like abortion gay marriage drug
legalism
opening borders not only to products but
also to people
they tell me that I have become a
Marxist because of this
well if I can fall into the category of
marxist because the understanding of
what libertarianism is in Latin America
is so vague of course you're gonna have
confusion all over the planet on one on
what Javier melaye portrays right
personally let's let's go every subject
that you touch because I think that if
we start focusing on policies instead of
focusing on individuals we dismantle the
populism that there is I don't like
analyzing
politicians as dogmatic
Messiahs I like analyzing policies to
see how the policies are more or less
libertarian I think the more that we do
that the less fanatism and dogmatism
we're gonna have and I think we're in a
world that highly needs that for the
putins that also notos the trumps but
also the Chavez de Ortegas the the the
Evo Morales the lulas of the world we
have we have people going blindly after
people after leader is instead of going
very strict after policies with Javier
melaye says to you that gay marriage is
something he doesn't believe because he
doesn't believe that the state should
regulate marriage I say well then what's
the proposal gonna be it's a straight
marriage gonna be something from the
past is he gonna take away the state in
every marriage
I don't think so right but it's a really
nice way of saying I'm not gonna touch
the issue so you know advancing in
sexual Liberty and Liberty to love
whoever you want to love in Latin
America I think is a huge one and also
differentiating that from using the
state to educate people and indoctrinate
people in things that you don't want
kids to be indoctrinated that's why the
state shouldn't get involved in
education because if the state is nasty
your kids are going to be Nazis if the
state is communism communist Etc and if
you go now to drugs when he says well
everybody is you know allowed to consume
whatever they want to consume that's
okay but drugs are not only about
consumption it's also about who is
producing them and we know as a fact
that the drug cartels from Colombia to
Fark to Mexico all the cartels have
Finance socialism of the 21st century
right it is one of the pillars and we as
Libertarians in the region have been
saying for decades that unless Latin
America
legalizes decriminalizes the production
of these substances we are not going to
have transparent politics because it's a
super highway of financing all these
leaders without any accountability
without any transparency so when he says
everybody can consume whatever the hell
they want
he's also like retrieving himself as a
Libertarian into taking action in these
issues right now when you go to
Argentina people are super concerned
about inflation about wages so they tell
you you know what I don't care about the
gays I don't care about the drugs I just
want my money to be a a healthy money I
just want to do business in a healthy
way I want my savings to be you know
guaranteed and I understand that because
Argentina has one of the worst
inflations that you can have and when
the economy you know it's it's pushing
ahead then of course that you're gonna
be okay so that's where we need to ask
ourselves if Javier Miller comes to
power is he going to have a Congress
that will support him into uh opening up
to the markets because Argentina
currently is one of the worst countries
in the world in the index of economic
freedom so you need to maybe dollarize
it to open up to new currencies
including cryptocurrencies which are big
in Argentina but they are illegal
there's there are two different uh
prices of dollars in Argentina the black
market one and the the one that the
government uses so even if in economy we
have to ask ourselves what is he going
to be capable of doing now regarding
abortion it is true that nowadays
argentinians conservative argentinians
that support Javier melaye and and other
leaders like him have paid more than 30
000 abortions yearly with their taxes
since abortion was something that uh it
started to be a state
introduced or managed in 2021
uh from from the policy of 2020 December
2020 right so you're talking about 30
000 abortions yearly and Uprising so
when he says that he's gonna take that
back he could also have The Stance of a
Libertarian which are not understood in
Latin America because you can be a
Libertarian and be against the state
paying for abortions but taking away the
state so that the market offers them
unless we as a Libertarians communicate
properly what are the libertarian ideas
Javier melee and other leaders will be
portrayed by the media as super far
right now the last issue that I want to
discuss supporting Trump Urban bolsonaro
and putting has become a one deal
package in Latin America and we have
been called not truly Libertarians when
we and I mean we like me Antonella Marty
the libertarian party of Spain or even
objectivists in Enron Center Latin
America where Maria Eduardo's sister
works when you say wait a minute I don't
think that Trump is is having
libertarian stance or bolsonaro you you
get crucified in social media and people
tell you that unless you are with them
you are not a truly bartarian so I think
that we have to understand what is it
that you know differentiates Javier
melee from uh Ronald Reagan Christian a
free market guy from like a true
libertarian and and I think the only way
of doing that is analyzing what
libertarian policy means
but so when I look at that list of his
stances on social policies I would agree
with you that you know the the abortion
issue is is a big wedge I mean that's a
wedge even uh within the American
libertarian movement there's there's
division on that topic um I think you're
saying that at the very least a
Libertarian could or you know you you're
you think that the correct libertarian
position would be no State funding for
abortion but allow people to uh you know
make their own decisions theirs is that
nonetheless yeah according to the
Encyclopedia of libertarianism which is
already from 2011. 30 percent of the
retirements are pro-life what we would
call you know anti-abortion 70 are
pro-choice right which I think is also
as and ran accurately say you can have a
pro-life statement for abortion but even
in the pro-life Libertarians they do not
agree that you should criminalize women
and put them in jail because abortion
should be considered a crime there are
interviews
and people who support him and have said
that we should use the state and the
Machinery of the state to criminalize
women who go under abortion how does
that enter the umbrella of
libertarianism even by
anarcho-capitalist I I say to them how
is it that you don't want to state but
you're going to have a private police
that is going to persecute a women and
their and their uterus like how is how
is that going to work you know and they
don't have a straight answer but they
want to make abortion something that the
state criminalizes yeah and then just so
I understand on these other topics where
he seemingly is in alignment with
libertarian philosophy on drug use or
sexuality uh you're saying that
um you know he's saying he's okay with
drug use but not offering a policy like
we need to end the prohibition of drug
sales in Argentina or in the case of gay
marriage he
um you know saying people can do
whatever they want but he's not actually
advancing like a equal protection for
gay couples in Argentina is that I just
want to make sure I'm understanding your
point is that a correct summation
absolutely it's like you know we if
libertarianism is all about individual
rights equal for everybody right now in
Latin America the the lesbian gays trans
they do not have equal rights in markets
for example you cannot if you're not
married you don't have the benefits that
straight couple have in order to have
inheritance in order to go to a cell
phone company and get a family package
for all your family if you're talking
about two lesbians they don't get those
benefits in the market you know what I
mean so those are things that marriage
gives you individual rights for straight
people that right now the LGBT community
does not have I think that as a living
Tyrion you can move forward to that even
even if you say that marriage shouldn't
be something that the state should
regulate okay but let's be equal to
everybody and then your libertarian
platform should be let's get let's get
rid of straight marriage and let's make
marriage something that only the market
uh does but then what happens you cannot
you can have a celebration of a gay
wedding but you cannot use you know
lawyers uh or or anything to protect
your rights that is the thing in Latin
America the same with prostitution
say well there's the sexual Market you
can do whatever you want but if you
don't decriminalize prostitution
prostitution keeps being something that
the black market market operates in
criminalization is is like even in the
United States during the prohibition you
would have a candidate saying help
people can drink whatever alcohol they
want to but he's not willing to end the
prohibition
what do you think of that critique
Eduardo uh and after this we're going to
bring in a couple more melee Clips so
that our our audience can really get a
sense of you know the kind of rhetoric
that he uses to to advance his ideas but
what do you think of Gloria's critique
of malay's you know social positions
that maybe he kind of throws a bone to
Libertarians but he's not actually
advancing policies that are going to
increase social freedom in Argentina
I think that Gloria is
sent right
perfect description of the way Javier
thinks
optimistic I think he was a kind of
middle of the road a little bit
collectivist and he started to
understand the benefits of individualism
and liberalism five years ago and he's
smart
he's very passionate I think his sense
of life is is conservative but he's
becoming more an individualist regarding
abortion for example his last
declaration he last speech says that
okay I will not
penalize abortion I'm not in favor of
that but I want to stop financing
abortions and that would become a little
bit very consistent with the libertarian
ideas I don't know if maybe his next
declaration is going to say the same but
it seems that he's running little by
little
way of uh of conservatives but at the
same time I'm afraid that that can also
happen with economic principles the idea
of closing the central bank that for me
is a great idea the idea of reducing all
taxes we had 167 taxis and he suggested
to stay with six or seven taxes to
reduce
uh the size of government to 20 percent
of the PBI expenditures so all that he
has been very aggressive very consistent
but for example his last declaration he
said that he doesn't want to keep
financing the corn he said the science
research and the whole country went
after him saying you are going to stop
financing research in science and
culture things that are so important
this is a broken country with people
making I don't know three thousand
dollars a year so with people searching
in in the garbage to eat you have 45 50
of people in poverty so a good president
would come and say we are going to cut
all expenditures we will have a healthy
money and a very very short and budget
so we
we are trying to advise Javier that if
we really gain the presidency
to just to act on principle just a very
small government very consistent and not
enter into those social issues that
Gloria describe so well his mind he's a
guy who's suffering his infancy a lot he
was being beaten by his parents and he's
he's full of
uh I don't know emotions that overflowed
him but I
I you know politics is of course maybe
one day we'll have glorious president of
Guatemala influencing all that in
America that happens one day I will be
there but and I think that's really
possible because little by little we
grow I don't know I will be able to see
it but they have expectations but for
the moment if you compare Malay with
I don't know uh Patricia bulrich or the
candidate for the Christina Christian Mr
Masa you see a guy with a different
sense of life I resent also some of his
conservative positions and I think that
of course they are going they are not
going to help him to in his position but
compare what what we had in the past is
is is something hey thanks for watching
that clip from my conversation with
Gloria Alvarez and Eduardo Marty about
the rise of Javier melee in Argentina
for the full conversation click right
here for another clip from that
conversation go right here